- Welcome back.
I'm today's guest host Howie Mandel.
Here with Terry Crews and my
daughter Jacqueline Schulz.
(audience applauds)
Pretty much all in the family this hour.
Now, if you ever wished you knew more
about your family's history,
our next guest can help.
She's an author from Louisiana
who captures memories
and turns them into actual written books.
She's what our season-long
partner Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "Kelly Clarkson
Show" calls unstoppable.
That's because she's writing history.
We have Olivia dialed in.
(audience applauds)
- Yeah.
- How are you?
- I'm doing great.
Thanks so much for having me.
- Oh, it's my pleasure.
It's the least I could do.
Anyway, you are a biographer.
This is, I find this fascinating
'cause everybody loves reading biographies
but what would be more important
than reading a biography
of somebody you care
about, you love, you know
you wanna know more about?
So explain how it works.
- Sure, so I write life story
books for everyday people.
For grandparents.
I write books for people,
usually 65 and older.
They're in their seventies, their eighties
or even their nineties.
And sometimes they call
me up to commission
me to write this life story
book for their family.
And other times it's
been their adult child
or their grandchild
commissioning me so that
the whole family can enjoy
their loved one's story forever.
The way I do this is based
off of verbal interviews.
I ask guided questions starting
with their earliest memories.
We go through their teen
years, their love stories
a whole lifetime of memories.
- [Terry] Wow.
- And I have personally written
over 40 of these life story books.
- Wow, and what inspired you to do this?
Oh, give her a hand.
(audience applauds)
- Yes.
40.
40 biographies.
What inspired, how did you get inspired?
What started you?
- My grandmothers inspired me to do this.
I grew up in South Louisiana,
where they are from
and where we all live.
And I grew up close to them.
I am still so close to them
and I was so surprised to learn
that I didn't know them quite as well
as I thought until I worked
on these life story books.
So I learned so much from
interviewing my grandmothers.
And after seeing what those
books meant to my own family,
I knew I wanted to do this for others.
- I have a grandmother who used to.
(audience applauds)
My grandmother used to steal
Yo-Yos from the neighbors
and give them to us.
I wish we had a place to write that down.
(Terry laughs)
Terry, do you have any relatives that
you think would be interesting?
- Oh absolutely.
I have a 95 year old grandmother.
- I met her at your star
on The Walk of Fame.
- The Walk of Fame, you met her.
- That's an amazing story.
- It's an amazing story.
I would love to get in contact with you
because she told me, I was writing my book
and she told me so many
stories that I didn't know
about my family.
- She's lived through so much.
- I mean, and this is
something you can pass
down to your kids and their kids.
It's something that could go on forever.
- These aren't short books, right?
These aren't pamphlets?
- No, these are full-length
life story books.
So here's one of my grandmother's books.
This one has 100 pages in it, for example.
And here's one a for
a World War II veteran
and lifelong educator.
And this one is closer to 200 pages.
So everyone is so different.
They are based off of verbal interviews
and after about 12 or 15 hours,
in small increments, of
talking with someone,
either remotely or in the
comfort of their home,
I write for 6 to 12 weeks usually.
And then I help them pick
their most cherished photos.
One of my favorite things
to do is to have them use
a pen and hand write
Chapter One, Chapter Two
and sign off their books in the end.
- I got a question, do you
ever have a spouse that says,
"Nah, that didn't happen."
(Olivia laughs)
You know what I mean?
Like, I can see my wife being
like, "No, that's not how it went at all."
- I'm not lying.
It's in a book.
(all laugh)
- Well, actually, not
too much because I work,
usually one-on-one with a subject,
and it's their book, it's their
story the way they tell it.
So that hasn't come up.
- Well I'm gonna call you.
I don't wanna do a whole
book 'cause I don't
have attention span, but I'd
love a pamphlet for the kids.
Of me.
(all laugh)
Anyways. thank you so much, Olivia.